MICHEL DEGRAFF: So if I were
to teach this course to a group
that would be much more diverse
than what we have here at MIT--
because I think--
so when we taught this
course this past Spring,
most students came
with a very open mind
trying to understand
the way, indeed,
race and language create
these hierarchies that are not
good for the country,
not good for the world,
and how to create more
inclusive societies.
But if I were to
teach this course
with a more diverse ideological
set of students, what I think
I would do is to include
more texts from, say, a more
conservative perspective.
In fact, some of the
students often they
would bring in clips
from, say, Breitbart
or from Rush Limbaugh, voices
that are very conservative
and some of them even
on the outright extreme.
And we use that for
teaching moments.
But if I were to
teach this class maybe
to a more diverse
group, what I would do
is to not take views so extreme,
but take some scholarly work
that could advocate,
say, for building walls
and then try to examine them
together in a respectful way.
So that way even students
on the right and on the left
could have a respectful
dialogue and try
to look at the data that might
support a particular view
versus the other.
And that would be a challenge.
But I think eventually that
would be a good challenge,
because one common motif
throughout the semester
was how do we take what we
learn here in this course
and make it available to
the wider public including
those who might want to
build walls and not bridges?
How do we translate all these
very important knowledge
of these important
findings about migration,
about equality?
How do we translate
that in a way
that it can be discussed
in the wider sphere?
And this remains a challenge
to the very end of the class.
There was no clear
answer on how to do that.
But I would hope that if we were
to teach to a broader audience,
we would come up with
the right way to do it.